कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि नए
एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम सीखने
वाले हैं जर्मन में पर्फेक्ट और प्लस कम
पर रख सकते हैं इसको इंग्लिश में बोलते
हैं प्रेसिडेंट पर्फेक्ट और पास पर फिर या
हिंदी में बोलते हैं पूर्ण वर्तमान काल और
पूर्ण भूतकाल
मैं तुझे पूर्ण वर्तमान कलर पूर्ण भूत का
इतने इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है जब जर्मंस लिखते
हैं लिखते हैं भूतकाल में जो सिंपल पास्ट
टेंस हमने एपिसोड 10 में सीखा था पर जब वह
day-to-day लाइफ में बोलते हैं तो वह
परफेक्ट टेंस का यूज करते हैं इसलिए बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट है तो वह कैसे करना है अब हम
सीखते हैं तो सबसे पहले व्हाट इस पर्फेक्ट
है यह पूर्ण वर्तमान काल क्या है कोई चीज
भूतकाल में घटी पर अभी जस्ट कंप्लीट हो गई
है मतलब उसने क्रिकेट खेला है उसने
क्रिकेट खेला है तो उसको आलरेडी क्रिकेट
खेल के हो गया है लड़की स्कूल पूर्ण
वर्तमान काल क्लियर है तो यह इंग्लिश में
कैसे बोलते हैं हम कि Help ले क्रिकेट
तोहरा देखोगी ही डेसप्लैट क्रिकेट कैसे हो
कि आप देखोगे तो जो है वह क्या है वो कर
रूप उसको हमने चलाया है अगर आए हैं वह
प्लेट क्रिकेट होता अगर मैंने अकेला होता
तो हमने के अलावा था तो वही है वह क्रिकेट
तो हमने क्या किया सेकेंड पोजीशन पर एक
ऑग्ज़ीलियरी वर्ब्स इसको बोलते हैं सा यह
कार्यक्रम पर व है वो और प्लेयर क्या है
प्लेयर उसका पार्टिसिपल उसको बोलते हैं कि
इंग्लिश में आपने वह तीन याद रखिए होंगे
गो वेंट गोन पीठ रिटर्न ड्रिंक डंग डंग
तुरंत इट यह है पास्ट पार्टिसिपल कि हमने
सीखा तो यह प्लेट जो है वह पार्टी से पहले
तो हमने इंग्लिश में क्या किया है कि
हेल्प लेट क्रिकेट हैव करूं और पार्टीज
पार्टिसिपल अत्यंत जर्मन यह कैसे होता है
देखते हैं और उससे वह थ्री स्टेप ठीक हैं
तो सबसे पहले
है कि हेल्प लैंड क्रिकेट जर्मन में वो
कायर हाट क्रिकेट की स्पीड देखिए फिर से
इन र हार्ट्स क्रिकेट के स्पेशल क्या-क्या
सेम है क्या क्या डिफरेंट है हम देखते हैं
कि का ऐड हमको पता है इसका हार्ट हमको पता
है क्रिकेट तो क्रिकेट है प्लेट जैसे वहां
पर पास्ट पार्टिसिपल था वैसे जर्मन में वह
गैस फील्ड है चेंज क्या है गैस फील्ड एंड
में गया है यह पहला रूम याद रखना जर्मन
में बाकी सब अंग्रेजी की तरह सिर्फ चेंज
क्या है इंग्लिश में हैव के बाद
डाइरैक्टली Play तथा जन मन में गेस्ट
हमेशा एंड में आएगा एक दम एंड में अगर
आपको ऐसे बोलना होता कि ही है स्पीड
क्रिकेट ऑन मंडे तो होता खैर रहट क्रिकेट
आम मेंटल जिस फील्ड गेस्ट हमेशा एंड नहीं
आता प्लेयर पहले रूल जो पार्टी अथवा
अपने गाजर मन में उसको पार्ट्स वाले बोलते
हैं पार्टिसिपल को वह हमेशा एंड में आएगा
अभी दूसरा अभी कुछ गैस फील्ड के अवसर बना
तो यह गैस प्रिंट कैसे बना तो वह बना
स्पेन में से गेम को हटाया स्पीशीज टाइम
बनाया पहले गे और एंड मिट्टी गैस फील्ड
नियर अनफॉर्चूनेटली अनफॉर्चूनेटली बहुत
सारे जेवर है जो रूल फॉलो ही नहीं करते
अगर आपको याद होगा हमने स्क्रीन का दूध
प्रिंस हमें मंत्री बनाया था वह
इंपोर्टेंट क्यों था क्योंकि मोर देन
नाइनटी पर सेंट आफ वर्क्स को फॉलो करते
हैं यह जो गैस पीड़ितों का रूल है जैसे
हमने सिंपल पास्ट टेंस फील्डर देखा था वह
मोस्ट इफेक्टिव वर्क नहीं करते तो हम क्या
करेंगे हम वही करेंगे जो हमने बाकी किसी
भी भाषा में किया था
मैं हिंदी में हमने जाना का गया कैसे किया
याद रख इंग्लिश में हमने गोवेरमेंट कैन गो
वेंट गोन चेतन को पता चलल हमने वह याद
रखना
कि जर्मन में भी हम ऐसे ही करेंगे तो अगर
हम क्या करेंगे गहन ज्ञान ज्ञान ज्ञान यह
हैंगिंग बेगमगंज हरप्रिया मत का तो सिंपल
पास्ट टेंस बना इष्ट व लर्न हैकिंग अहम
याद रखेंगे और उसके बाद उसका जो पार्टी
सिर्फ ₹100 व हम याद रखेंगे आपको एक हर
वर्ग के लिए दो नए वर्ड्स सिर्फ अलग याद
रखने होंगे पर मेरा यकीन मानो इस नोट देख
हार्ड और जैसे-जैसे आप प्रैक्टिस करते
जाओगे वह आपको एकदम आसान हो जाएगा तो अभी
आपको स्क्रीन पर जो हमने 250 वर्ड्स जब
सीखे थे तो जो इंपॉर्टेंट वर्ष के थे उनके
सिंपल पास्ट टेंस वाला इशू वाला रूप और
उनका पास टिप्स वाले रूप को मिलेगा कि है
लिंग के आंगन आपको चाहिए तो अभी आप
स्क्रीन पॉज कर सकते हैं और अपने पेपर पर
लिख कर ले सकते हैं या फिर जब भी आप यह
पढ़ने वाले वह पांच पांच इनको लिख कर ले
सकते हैं
स्ट्रांग्ली बिलीव कि जब आप एक बार कागज
पर लिख कर लेते हो तो आपको यह ज्यादा याद
रहता है तो प्लीज मेरे कटरा है व्यक्ति से
एक बार आप यहां से पौन इंच करके इसको अपने
कागज पर लिख कर लीजिए मतलब हम हर वर्ग का
गेम किंग के गंगा ऐड कर नहीं देखते जाएंगे
कि उसमें बहुत ज्यादा समय लगेगा और वह आप
खुद कर सकते हो तो इससे कंट्रोल सबको समझ
में आया इवन ठोसे सॉफ्ट रूल की गैस फ़ील्ड
हो सकता है हम हर वर्ग के लिए उसका जो
पार्ट इच्छुक है वह याद रखेंगे यह सेकंड
है
मैं अभी घर सिंपल क्या है कि अगर आप
इंग्लिश में देखो तो हर बार है वहीं दूसरी
ओर होता है बताए हैं वह प्लेट क्रिकेट आई
हैव ईटन पिज़्ज़ा आई हेव द्रमुक को वह
चलता है कि है द्रमुक को हैव फॉर चलाते
हैं पर हमेशा और व्यावसायिक परिसर में फोन
है वह रहता है जर्मन में थोड़ा सा लगे
जर्मन मोस्ट ऑफ द टाइम्स की इस खबर
क्रिकेट अश्लील पर ऐसे कुछ हुआ है इस
बिंदु विशेष वगैरह कुछ जगहों पर आता है कि
मैं थोड़ा सा कि यहां पर सही नहीं होता है
तो एक चीज कॉमन है इन वर्ष में जगह चेंज
हो रही है
आज हम इन मतलब आना गहन मतलब जाना फौरन
मतलब प्रयोग करना राजधर्म मतलब यात्रा पर
जाना या फिर लीगल मतलब डे इन सब क्या हो
रहा है आपकी जगह चेंज हो रही है तो जब आप
की जगह चेंज होगी तब तक आप एक पल के लिए
मैं वहॉन् टू अभी हैव इंग्लिश में था पर
यहां पर घाघरे हुई है इसलिए नहीं लगेगा इस
बिना पर लेंगे क्यों क्योंकि इस आप होते
तो दो मिनट भून लेंगे हम होते तो इसलिए
तरफ गांव को तो फिर भी ना लगता है
ए क्लियर अभी ऐसे थोड़े से वर्ग हैं आई एम
फुल आफ फन मतलब सो जाना आह्वाहन टूटना की
जगह नहीं चेंज और पर कि स्टेट चेंज हो रही
है उनको भी टाइम लगता है और लाइट बंद जैसा
एक वर्ग है उसको भी टाइम लगता है वह इतना
इंपोर्टेंट नहीं है वह अपने डेकोरेट में
इतना यूज नहीं करने वाले आपके लिए
इंपोर्टेंट क्या है जब ज्यादा चेंज होगी
तब जैन का आरोप लगाना है तो बेगम फिर से
थोड़ा सा रिवाइज करते हैं पहला रोल किया
था कि है प्लेट क्रिकेट एयर हॉट क्रिकेट
एसपी विल स्पीक एंड में जाएगा से कंट्रोल
किया था ख यौवन धोते जस्ट आफ्टर नून हम
क्या करेंगे हम याद रखेंगे यह हैंगिंग कि
बैंगन और तीसरा रोल हमने देखा नार्मल यह
बनाएगा परिचय जबकि तक जारी रहेगा थोड़े
सेंटेंस बनाते हैं तो आपको थोड़ा सा
ज्यादा चैनल होगा ठीक है
को सबसे पहले थोड़े से यह वर्ष के पास
टिप्स भाई देख लेते हैं तो आपके लिए इजी
हो गए एक्सचेंज होता है खाना उसका होता है
क्वेश्चन क्वेश्चन स्प्रिंकल पीना उसका
होता है कि द्रोण पुष्पी ललिता बिष्ट तो
हमने देखा है और यह तिनका होता है ज्ञान
गंगा अब इसका यूज करके हम चार सेंटेंस
बनाते हैं
को सबसे पहले आई है वह विंटर्स सही इस
हार्बर पिज़्ज़ा यह क्वेश्चन यह सब ऐड में
गया हवन का रुख इस हवा पिता के किशन आई
हेव अदरक को हम क्रम को इस हबक मित्रों कल
मित्रों कंटेंट में आया प्लेट रिक्वेस्ट
सिंपल है इस हफ्ते गांव स्पीड और आई है
वांट टू पर ग्लू ज्ञान है इसलिए क्या होगा
का यह करूं इस बिना खबर लें कि बैंगन जो
है एकदम सिंपल ग्रेट अगर आपको रूल ठीक से
पता है तो इस अ वेरी वेरी सिंपल थी सिर्फ
मैं एक चीज ध्यान रखनी है यह प्लेट
क्रिकेटर हैं क्रिकेट के इस फील्ड
कि जिस फील्ड एंड में डिसपेल्ड बनाना है
और अगर जगह चेंज हुई तो टाइम करो दैट से
और अगर आपको यह परफेक्ट टेंस क्लियर है
अगर आपको यह परफेक्ट टेंस क्लियर है तो
नेक्स्ट 5 मिनट में पांच मिनट में एक और
नया टेंस सीखने वाले पुलिस पर पर या फिर
पास पर्फेक्ट या फिर हिंदी में पूर्ण
भूतकाल मतलब क्या उसने क्रिकेट खेला था
हां सब कुछ जो बहुत पुराना है उसने
क्रिकेट खेला था तो इसमें अब देखो आपने
क्या चेंज किया उसने क्रिकेट खेला है उसने
क्रिकेट खेला था फिर फकीरवा कि कुछ चेंज
नहीं किया इंग्लिश ने भी वही किया आए हैं
और प्लेट क्रिकेट इंग्लिश ने आय हेट प्लेट
क्रिकेट किया
जो है वो का ही रूप है पास कंट्रोल आरोप
लगाया बाकी सब SIM है जब नंबर भी वही करना
है आपको याद है हवन का जो पास्ट टेंस रुख
किया था हटन हद तक कैसे चलता है वह भी
आपको पता है डिजाइन का पास्ट टेंस रूप था
वायरल वायरल कैसे चलता है वह भी आपको
बताया तो अभी आपको क्या करना है जहां पर
अपने हां पन का आरोप लगाया था वहां पर खटम
का जहां पर साइन का वारंट का पड़े
एग्जांपल लेते हैं आए हैं डिटेल पिसर
कि इस हट पिज़्ज़ा क्वेश्चन आए थे अदरक को
इस हट को वितरण आईएस हेल्पलेस क्रिकेट इस
हद तक हेल्थ और आई हैव गोन टू फर लु आईएफ
वांट गया था जहां चेंज हुई तो इसलिए दही
का पास्ट टेंस स्वरूप इस वार रख लेंगे
बैंगल सिंपल कुछ भी नया नहीं हमको पता थी
वायरल दूसरी आज की दोनों same Joint कि और
हम एक नया प्लेटफॉर्म पर ले जाएंगे यही
करने वाले हैं जो कि उनका यूज करते हुए
आगे आने वाले हैं
लुट कि सबको आज का कंटेंट समझ में आया
होगा परफेक्ट और फिर उस पॉइंट पर हमने
क्या किया सिर्फ तीन स्टैंड पहला स्टेप
किया था जो पास्ट पार्टिसिपल या पठित्वा
बोलते हैं वह एंड में जाएगा गेस्ट होंगे
इस अनोखे आंगन दूसरा हमने बोला कि वह याद
रखना है हमको के आंगन क्वेश्चन जो भी है
वह और तीसरा हमने बोला जब नार्मल यहां पर
लगाएंगे इस हवा क्रिकेट विच फील्ड जगह
चेंज हुई तो अधीन लगाएंगे इस बिना खबर
रिंगटोन मुझे आशा है आप सबको यह परफेक्ट
टेंस आफ उस फॉर कम परफेक्ट टेंस इससे
आसानी से समझ में आया होगा फिर मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धनिया